So if I have this graph,
segmenting the image is just
breaking the graph into segments.
So here I'm showing you that I, I took
all those points I had before, and
I broke this thing into three segments.
So that would mean that there
were three regions in this image.
And the idea is that what I want
to do is I want to delete links
that are between the segments, right?
So maybe there used to be a link that
connected this point to that point, and
it's been broken, all right?
So I'm going to delete links
that go between segments.
And so,
which links should be easiest to break?
Well, obviously those with
the lowest affinity, right?
because if I break them they're saying,
you know, the blue pixel and
the red pixel, which maybe have
great distance in my feature space.
So, they have a very low
affinity between them.
By the way, here's a,
an actual example of segmenting this
tiger against the background, and
you can see that it's got spatially
contiguous regions by, by, doing that.
So, what I need to do is I need to
construct a distance function, such that
similar pixels will end up being in the
same segments, if, if they're near by.
And dissimilar pixels,
ones that are very different,
will end up in different segments.